of strong opposition in this coming game
the hands are Shake is there and we see
that looked to me like E4 and is that a
sicilan wow nidorf well I don't believe
that Magnus will be interested in going
in for wow no he does CD okay let's go
let's see a sharp
nidorf I'm enjoying the start of this
game and Magnus plays Rook G1 oh yes oh
I'm happy about this Peter we are going
a g push the near future well unless
black plays the move H5 which can I
think Anish has played it against Magnus
Carson I have been commenting that game
from the Champions chest but no Niar
goes Knight C6 that's a
surprise G4 played and it's a pawn
sacrifice because if you take on D4
first and then take on G4 white doesn't
have enough Defenders over there but
you're wasting time you're spending
precious time with your pieces and white
will then Castle Queen side so it's a
pawn sacrifice that is
Justified yes for sure and we also see
the evoluation bar jumping in white
favors after the G4 black plays
G6 wasn't it something that Magnus
himself against Yan yashi when Yan uh
was playing Rook G1 against Magnus
himself that that does ring a bell and
and that means that you've experienced
with both colors and that can be a good
thing because you can sort of turn the
board around in your head and think
about what black strategies are but it
also could have caused him some
discomfort and now he's like let me try
it from the white side so Bishop E2 to
my eyes is the most natural move for
white but there may be a way for black
to get out at some moment with the
Knight getting to F4 but I don't think
tactically it works in this position
yeah Bishop E2 very tempting and Magnus
has played it targeting that Knight on
H5 that's an awkward piece of course if
black can somehow establish a control of
the dark Square
with Knight F4 and E5 it would be great
but I don't see that really
realistically happening yeah black could
take everything then we are getting into
territory I'm talking about and then
follow it up with E5 Landing the Knight
on F4 but the black pole on D6 will be a
big
weakness and the E5 Pawn push is great
on one hand because you gain access to
F4 as you were talking about but then it
leaves the D6 Pawn behind so we see all
of the pieces trade on D4 the on h8 is
under attack so E5 here it comes and
look at Magnus if I'm seeing this
correctly he moved his Queen but oh no
he hasn't moved his Queen yet has he I
thought he grabbed his Queen but it
looks like it's still on D4 I'm thinking
do you br go to E3 D2 or even B4 just to
poke at the B7 Pawn exactly Queen E3 was
the Thematic move but if Magnus has
already posed it was kind of the clear
indication there it is on the board
confirmed Queen B4 Knight F4 long
castles look at that back for D6 pawn
and not only the pawn white might also
be able to transfer that Bishop Bishop
C4 Bishop BC protect everything making
sure that you have access to the D5
Square the pawn on D6 is falling the
opening was a huge success for Magnus
I'm glad you told me to look at the pawn
on D6 because I don't think it's going
to be there very long the rook and the
queen are lined up against it at black
Castle King side white just takes the
pawn on D6 King E7 is out of the
question I know it saves your Pawn for
the moment but your king is in the
center and all of White's pieces are
aiming in that direction so I would not
be brave enough to play a move like that
and if that's the case extra Pawn for
white free hand in the end
game yes that's why maybe even if black
does know and Nial gives up basically
both pawns but of course white can only
take one please take on D6 or please
take on B7 but let me coordinate my
pieces and Magnus says I want none of it
well
Peter I hate to take our attention away
from this game especially as heating up
we quickly need to go to board two yand
pomi with the black piece against denil
dubov uh because the result has been
relayed as a draw but if I'm not
mistaken when you pull up this board and
show everybody what is happen in this
game this is the actual final position
of the game look at what happened in
this one look at they play no but be
careful because actually there is the
certain danger that the Arbiter can uh
forfeit you for this I think it happened
in in all times in something like in the
80s when two friends played like this
they were given two
zeros keep going just I want to show
everybody how this game finished just
move by move the knights just danced
around and then they went to each
other's starting Square so the game
ended up being a draw U because they
agreed to it and you can of course
double forfeit the players for not
playing for not trying but what I don't
understand is when people make the
Berlin draw why is there any better by
making a force draw out of the opening
so it's not my ruling to make I think
that I would prefer to see players play
I'm always against the draw offer I want
to see Fighting Chess I'm glad we're
back to this game on board one between
Magus Carlson and Nial sarin yes exactly
and we were discussing that uh which
Pawn Magnus will take the D6 Pawn or the
B7 Pawn all of a sudden who takes the
first pawn it is black queen take G5 did
Magnus really blunder this possibility
now he's very upset and look at the
clock situation Magnus down to a minute
but Nial only has 25 seconds and when
you don't take on D6 when you can you
may regret it so the queen takes on G5
there are discovered checks against the
white king but Bishop takes E6 it
unleashes The Rook against the queen on
G5 as well so Knight d3's double check
looks very powerful but I don't think oh
is this all happening I don't think it
actually wins black
material yes well there will be also
Queen takes G1 that's uh but Queen take
G1 doesn't seem good yeah Knight takes
B4 of course yeah this is correct Queen
take G1 would have been a blunder since
the Knight is protecting The Rook all
right what do we see
here Mass liquidation and White's Pawn
structure is better but black gets very
quick activity white stole the where did
the B Pawn Just Go why'd he sacrifice
that yeah well he is lying on some
activity besides he only has 25 seconds
he he does not have a chance to think
but he's about to lose his a pawn as
well and at this stage the Black Knight
jumps into D4 the a pawn is gone maybe
we just zoom in on the board because uh
it seems like the relay is falling
behind the camera so if we can just look
at the Players here black has taken a
pawn right in front diagonally from the
white king but if we do a quick count
black only has four pawns remaining
white seems to have
five yeah and ni done to 12 seconds what
do you do oh he's going passive I don't
love the look of that because he could
have taken F2 he realized not but the
quantity of material but the quality of
the outside pass Pawn so he has stopped
the a pawn in its tracks but Peter I'm
liking white position yes of course uh
the a pawn is is extra minus taking his
time he feels that this is very
important moment yeah he goes A4 King F7
Nial at least makes sure that he
controls he activates the king he needs
to get some
activity and Magnus by the way down
under 10 seconds so he's Frozen he needs
to make a move I would just play H4 or
something like that he gives a check on
B7 and he actually grabs the H7 Pawn
Yeah but now luk B8 is Conant play
Knight B5 okay that was the trick but
how long you can hold on to this yeah
Rook E2 there's pressure on the B2 Pawn
Rook H6 goes after G6 so both sides will
have their kings and some danger here
wow all the pawns V for Rook G takes G6
check exactly have six check Magnus
played it with one second left by the
way Rook takes G6 so he's just giving
checks to gain a little bit of time if
he takes the Knight on B5 Rook oh he
offered a draw draw is agreed and it is
a draw by position so it's not like it
was a draw for out of nowhere yeah it
was a Perpetual check wow what a save by
ni and this is what what can happen the
players discussing the game Magnus feels
that he missed the chance but his
problem was that the Rook on G2 was kind
of passive and with 10 seconds on
the you always you you need your pieces
to to play together and uhha saved
it great defense from Niall